2% of black Americans approve of the job that
Donald Trump is doing.
Uh, there are lots of narratives that are
completely false and yet endlessly repeated
by Donald Trump and his parasitic boot lickers
who hang on his every word.
And one of those narratives is the idea that
Donald Trump is just doing better for black
Americans on every metric.
And that is a result.
Black Americans support Trump.
Well, I don't know more than they did in the
past, more than they support other Republican
presidents who knows exactly what the metric
they're using is.
And Donald Trump will often tout this.
He'll say, I'm doing better with the black
Americans, or as he sometimes calls them the
blacks, then who knows who, and it's kind
of a weird thing to say from the outset.
Um, and uh, the reality is that it's also
not true.
Some of the things Donald Trump we'll talk
about are, uh, black unemployment, uh, wages
for black Americans among other things.
But we now have data.
There's a new Quinnipiac poll that breaks
down this information.
And I want to look at some of the interesting
numbers on it now.
When asked, do you approve of how Donald Trump
is handling his job?
You will notice that two 2% of black Americans
approve of the job Donald Trump is doing as
president of the United States.
That's the sell in red.
On the chart that I'm showing you on the screen,
you might also notice that Donald Trump's
approval rating is only 35% among women.
That's the blue say shaded cell on the image
that we have on screen.
And one last notable thing.
Normally support of Republicans goes up with
age.
The older groups are successively more and
more likely to support the Republican.
Right now, approval of Trump, Trump among
65 and over Americans is lower than among
those aged 50 to 64 notice the green shaded
cell on the chart.
So a number of interesting things to talk
about here.
Number one is that not surprisingly, once
again, Donald Trump's coalition is not really
much of a coalition with the exception of
some Hispanic support that he's enjoying about
28 or 30% I believe Donald Trump's constituency
is basically middle aged white men.
That is the primary constituency of Donald
Trump.
And what's fascinating about that is that
there are groups that are disproportionately
made of middle aged white men, uh, that are
not doing well under Donald Trump thing to
Midwestern farmers.
Historically lifelong Republican Midwestern
farmers who are not doing well under Donald
Trump because of the tariffs.
But as I've said before, just because his
key demographic groups aren't doing well as
a result of his policy does not mean that
they are going to go out and vote for a Democrat.
So that's something to keep in mind.
So let's get back to the black Americans thing.
The massive victory with black Americans that
Donald Trump has been touting two years now.
He's been saying he's making America greater
than ever for black people and 2% approve
of the job that Donald Trump is doing.
Now we already know what the Trumpists are
going to say.
If you present them with this information,
they will say, David, that's not because Trump
isn't doing good things for black Americans.
It's because black people are on the plantation.
They've been bamboozled by Democrats into
being against Republicans no matter what the
Republican does for them.
Which is maybe the most patronizing thing
that can be said about a group of voters,
that they simply don't care what happens.
They don't base their support on what Donald
Trump is doing.
They just support Democrats over Republicans
because they are, you know, apply whatever
phrase you want, bamboozled on the plantation,
whatever.
Uh, and, and this is, um, of course extraordinarily,
uh, disrespectful ignores that black Americans
may not support Trump because of his racially
tendered policies and his racial [inaudible]
comments.
And the two years of playing coy with white
nationalism, give me a break.
So the important point here is Trumpus will
make a lot of noise about Candace Owens and
blacks.
It this totally failed movement.
It's almost like a fake movement to get black
people to exit the democratic party as if
it's some kind of irrational choice to vote
for Democrats.
Trumpists will cheer diamond and silk.
These are two women who are black and love
Trump.
If you haven't heard of them, great.
Don't even bother to look them up.
They're totally toxic and terrible.
Trumpists will cheer that.
You know, I don't know.
Ben Carson is part of Donald Trump's cabinet.
And then when you look at the numbers, when
the rubber meets the road, 2% of black Americans
support Donald Trump.
The narrative is false.
Do not fall for it, but do follow the David
Pakman show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
I also posted to my Instagram page today,
uh, David dot Pacman.
I posted a video from yesterday's Twitch live
stream where something happened to my microphone
where my voice went down in octave and people
started calling me David, Chad man on stream.
That's my latest post at David dot.
Pacman on Instagram.
Make sure you're following me there.
We will take it
quick break.